This pup is a wiz with a paintbrush.
Hunter, the Shiba Inu is also known as Pawcasso.
And you can see why.
His owners say they discovered his artistic talents...
...while they were trying to channel his energy into a productive activity.
He really needed a lot of exercise.
He needed a lot of mental stimulation,
So, we did a lot of training and tricks and things like that with him.
Just so that he can stay engaged and not destroy the house.
Denise Lo says she got the idea...
...when she and her husband were looking for artwork for their dining room.
Denise says it took about a week of practice for him to learn how to put brush to paper.
But now that he's got the hang of it, he's unstoppable.
He's not only making art for his own family,...
...he now has his own Etsy shop where his Instagram fans can buy his work.
They go from around 50 dollars a piece.